[Musique]
le 1er septembre dernier Michel au
bonsawin est devenu officiellement la
première autochtone à se voir attribuer
l'un des 9 sièges au plus haut tribunal
du pays originaire de la petite
communauté francophone de Elmer dans le
Nord ontarien membre à benakise de la
Première nation d'odanac la juge aux
bonsawin arrive à la Cour suprême avec
un regard unique sur la réalité des
peuples autochtones avec cette
nomination et celle du juge makmout
Jamal l'an dernier le tribunal
reflète-t-il mieux la diversité
culturelle canadienne j'ai posé la
question à la juge aux bancsawin qui
nous a reçu dans l'ancêtre de la Cour
suprême madame la juge bonjour merci
d'être avec nous oui bonjour madame en
2019 je vais un reportage dans lequel
vous parliez de vos rêves en disant
j'aimerais être une meilleure juge et
qui sait peut-être un jour être juge à
la Cour suprême
deux ans plus tard trois ans non je
votre salaire arriver si rapidement
c'est une belle surprise mais c'est
toujours un rêve comment comment on
réagit quand on reçoit l'appel du
Premier ministre qui dit j'ai pensé à
vous j'aimerais vous rencontrer
super excité je dois dire puis je me
rappelle de l'appel un numéro je
reconnaissais pas j'ai pris l'appel puis
mon époux était il voyage toxicité et
puis il me faisait des visages
donc super excité vous êtes là première
femme autochtone siège au plus haut
tribunal du pays
qu'est-ce que ça apporte à la Cour
suprême d'après vous cette présence moi
je pense à la même un point de vue qui
est unique comme une franco-tarienne du
Nord d'un petit village francophone
comme une mère autochtone nous avons
quand même des vécu uniques puis
j'espère que ça l'amène une perspective
qui est unique et quelque chose de
nouveau à la cour pourquoi c'est
important d'avoir cette sensibilité là
ici
quoi c'est important comme dans les
autres sensibilités aussi c'est pour que
le monde puisse se voir refléter au plus
haut tribunal au Canada puis aussi quand
même comme personne autochtone c'est
nous les peuples fondateurs nous y
étions ici il y a des mille années puis
c'est vraiment important quand même que
nous avons une voix au Canada est-ce que
est-ce que la réalité autochtone était
mal reflétée avant absolument je crois
que oui puis on a vu vraiment tant qu'à
moins de déclic avec la commission de
vérité et réconciliation avec
l'honorable Mary Sinclair c'est là je
pense que c'était vraiment ouvert ou qui
avait des discussions au sujet des
pensionnats l'impact sur les gens qui
ont assisté à l'impact
intergénérationnel
puis aussi avec les découvertes à
cameloop donc c'est vraiment je trouve
elle fait de la neige dans les dernières
années au sein au sein de la communauté
juridique au tribunal est-ce que c'est
cette mauvaise c'est toujours
représentation de la réalité totale à
cause des torts d'après vous à votre
peuple
je pourrai pas de ça causer des tasses
c'est juste peut-être qu'il y avait un
manque de connaissance Qu'est-ce que ça
va changer pour l'audition il y en a des
causes 13 à des questions liées à des
questions très autochtones qui s'en
viennent qu'est-ce que ça change je me
présente je sais pas si ça change
quelque chose en particulier ça l'amène
un point de vue qui est unique quand
même puis faut se souvenir quand même je
suis une parmi neuf juges j'ai une voix
la table donc ça l'amène ma perspective
comme une femme autochtone mais c'est
une nouvelle voie je vois qu'il porte
quand même oui vous avez été le cible de
critique au moment de votre nomination
on a on entre autres ciblé le fait que
vous aviez peut-être pas toute
l'expérience que ça prenait dans le
passé vous êtes très jeune quand même
vous aviez peut-être pas toute
l'expérience que ça prenait pour
justifier cette nomination là comment
vous avez reçu ces critiques moi je
crois la fin de la journée il va y avoir
des critiques ça fait pas de différence
puis moi je me suis dit puis une des
choses je dois dire un de mes
il va y avoir des critiques c'est normal
ça arrive à tout moment puis Lipa toutes
les critiques puis faites ne t'en fais
pas puis vraiment j'ai suivi ces
conseils vous avez dit dans le passé que
c'est important de sensibiliser les
Canadiens à certaines réalités d'automne
dans le monde judiciaire entre autres
l'important taux d'incarcération et
peuples autochtones vous faites ça comme
comment ça se traduit pour vous ici vous
faites ça commence sensibiliser les
Canadiens moi c'est un de mes buts puis
moi j'ai toujours cru c'était en
réplique au 94 recommandations de la
Commission de vérité des conciliation
parce qu'il y en a qui traite
d'éducation et de justice puis moi en
pratique comme un vocale puis comme juge
j'ai été conférencière de l'Est à
l'Ouest canadien puis c'était vraiment
de parler de des photos d'incarcération
les principes de l'adules pense que ça
fonctionne ça c'est un devoir que je me
suis donné parce que c'est important
d'en discuter pour que les gens soient
connaissant pas juste au public mais
aussi à l'intérieur du milieu juridique
est-ce que quelque part il y a une
notion de éducationnelle de faire
connaître cette réalité-là au Canadien
est-ce que est-ce qu'on souhaite est-ce
que vous souhaitez faire changer les
choses renverser ces tendances je sais
pas si renversé mais moi c'est pour
éduquer c'est pour que les gens soient
plus conscients de l'impact des
pensionnats au sujet des retours
d'incarcération c'est des choses
vraiment faut que qu'on en discute vous
avez beaucoup parlé de votre
votre passé votre vos racines
francontariennes dans le Nord l'Ontario
vous siégé à une cour suprême ou on
exige le rénovant le bilingus est-ce que
c'est important pour vous ça ici moi
pour moi absolument j'ai toujours cru
que le bilingus mettait très important
d'être capable de se prononcer dans sa
langue de choix en français ou en
anglais qui sont les langues officielles
du Canada moi ça m'a toujours été
quelque chose de valable c'est quelque
chose que nous à la maison nous avons
enseigné à nos enfants puis nous parlons
français à la maison puis ça m'a
toujours aidé tout le long de ma
carrière il y a des gens des détracteurs
qui diraient cette règle-là elle empêche
peut-être la sélection de bons candidats
sur la simple base qui sont pas en
mesure de s'exprimer en français vous
dites quoi ça moi je vais pas rentrer
dans l'aspect politique de ce choix-là
donc je peux juste vous dire que pour
moi c'était quelque chose de très
bénéfique puis j'ai toujours été
vraiment encouragé de voir le
bilinguisme à les différents des
tribunaux la Cour suprême dont vous
faites partie est-ce qu'elle représente
bien le Canada présentement je trouve
qu'il y a eu des grands améliorations
puis je crois que oui je crois que les
décisions qui ont émises auparavant je
peux pas croire que quelqu'un dirait
sans les juges par exemple auparavant il
y avait des mauvaises décisions je
dirais absolument
pas ce point-là je crois que les
décisions auparavant étaient bien
déterminées basées sur les dossiers qui
étaient présentés mais nous comme des
gens diverses nous ajoutons une
différence perspective à la cour vos
défis à vous vous avez atteint ce que
vous aviez établi dans une des entrevues
récentes comme étant le Pinnacle de ce
que vous vouliez atteindre qu'est-ce qui
vient ensuite
je vais commencer par dépendre la
première qui est c'est quoi les défis
pour moi c'est vraiment
d'utiliser ma patience je dois dire moi
j'ai toujours été une juge qui entendait
un dossier puis ensuite assez rapidement
vous pouvez rédiger une décision pour la
sortir rapidement ici c'est une grande
machine c'est très différent vous êtes
plusieurs on est plusieurs puis à la fin
de la journée c'est qu'il faut choix
patients que ma décision que j'aurais
émise en dinde de quelques mois la cause
supérieure ici la cause prime peut
prendre jusqu'à un an puis c'est quand
même quelque chose